a new statue has briefly appeared on a
plinth in the English port city of
Bristol where a few weeks ago the
long-standing monument to a slave trader
was thrown into the harbor the statue of
Edward Colston was torn down during a
major anti-racism rally last month it
later was retrieved by the authorities
and taken away now here's what went up
in its place on Wednesday it's a statue
of campaigner Jenn Reed recreating the
moment she stood on the plinth after the
rally and raised her fist in the air at
you're more than a few on lockers to
here's what some of the people thought
about it I think is absolutely fantastic
it's good for the people of Bristol is
good for black lives matter and I think
personally I think it should stay this
statue was erected illegally I think as
a democracy we should be able to vote
for what statues are erected and also
disagree with the way that the Kolski
statue was taken down I individually
like the piece what we've seen in
Bristol the city that the first actually
was taken down that started all of these
things overall people are happy the
statue was gone there should have been a
debate about that just to put out there
that new statue has since been taken
down and put in a museum the city's
mayor says there needs to be a
democratic process for the people of
Bristol to decide the future of the
plinth brexit Party co-founder Catherine
Blake Locke says people taking it upon
themselves to install a statue that's a
dangerous precedent it's anti-democratic
I think the fact that they didn't apply
for planning permission and they put the
force fit to put it up in the middle of
the night shows you actually what this
movement is about this movement isn't
about the people Bristol the people if
they really wanted to they could apply
to have planning permission to put this
up they didn't it sets a precedent that
a few people can decide and that
democracy does not matter anymore
you